the dow jones industrial average just
hit 30k
for the first time since its inception
in 1896.
after a long rally the dow surged to
this milestone as investors cheered
breakthroughs in three separate covit 19
vaccines
offering hope the economy may soon get
back to normal
it also followed democrat joe biden's
victory in the presidential election
and the general services administration
clearing the way for the
president-elect's transition process
easing investors concerns about a
drawn-out period of uncertainty
this latest stock market rise was driven
by stimulus programs from the fed
and leadership from tech stocks the
speed of the climb from twenty thousand
to thirty thousand has still been
astounding despite
what we saw earlier in the year which
was a huge sell-off in february and
march
it took about 18 years for the dow to
get from 10 000 to 20 000
and it's been less than four years of
the dow to climb from 20 000 to 30
thousand
the new high comes around nine months
after the dow plummeted from investors
fearing the economic impacts of the
coronavirus
during this period of historic
volatility on several occasions the dow
fell
more than three percent in a single day
after reaching its february 12
peak the blue chip index fell nearly 40
percent in just six weeks
hitting its lowest closing level since
2016.
when it comes to the dow milestones like
30 000 serve
as an indicator of how well shares of a
select group of large
technology companies have done and in
that regard the biggest contributor to
the dow's rally
apple underscores the influence of the
tech sector on the global economy during
the pandemic
more on the dow's other leaders and
laggards in a moment
but first let's take a look at how the
index works
the dow looks a lot different today than
it did in 1896 when it was first created
with 12
smokestack companies so these were
companies like tennessee coal and iron
general electric
that were old economy companies today
the index has 30 stocks that are
weighted by stock price
and we've seen tech companies like apple
and microsoft and more recently
salesforce really have a big influence
editors at the wall street journal help
select the 30 companies that make up the
dow
those stocks are generally seen by
investors as the pillars of the stock
market
when it comes to the dow the more
expensive the stock the more
polar company has so a two percent stock
price gained by
united health would add more points to
the dow than say
a two percent gain by cisco its stock
price is a fraction of united health
other stock indexes like the s p 500 are
very different from the dow because they
weight companies by market
capitalization so companies with the
biggest market values like apple will
have a much bigger influence on the s p
500
than they do on the dow that means just
a handful of stocks have driven up the
value of the dow over the last few years
take boeing for example before two
deadly crashes the grounding of the 737
max
fleet and the pandemic the aerospace
company was driving the dow's gains
more recently tech companies like apple
and microsoft have taken the baton from
boeing and
overshadowed the declines in shares of
former market leaders exxon mobil
ibm and ge while recently the
coronavirus crisis has been a driving
factor in the success of certain
companies
and the travails of others political
factors have long played a critical role
in moving markets
the are paying a fair share of taxes
even as the stock market shatters
records our stock market has reached an
all-time high today 2017 was a pretty
good year for the stock market
the world's major economies were growing
in sync corporate profits were rising
and the dow continued to steadily climb
higher
in november the release of the gop's tax
cut plan would have a direct impact on
those 30 companies that make up the dow
with this plan we are making pro growth
reforms
so that yes america can compete with the
rest of the world
investors consider the tax cuts good for
big business
the dow is moved day-to-day by the same
factors that influenced the broader
stock market
these could be economic indicators
political questions
or recently momentum signals 2018
was full of uncertainty there were trade
tensions with china
that threatened globalized businesses
bottom line in particular with china
we're going to be doing a section
301 trade action
it could be about 60 billion dollars
but that's really just a fraction of
what we're talking about
and president trump criticized the
federal reserve for a dip
in the markets i think the fed has gone
crazy
in 2019 the fed cut interest rates for
the first time since the financial
crisis
not just once but three times today we
decided to lower the interest rates for
the third time this year
other central banks around the world
took actions to stabilize their
economies as well
and towards the end of 2019 some
progress was made after months of trade
talks between the us and china
president trump agreed to a limited deal
with beijing
dropping threatened tariffs as china
agreed to purchase more goods from the
u.s
by january of 2020 the president had
signed the first phase of a trade
agreement
and the dow in the early months of the
year with gdp and unemployment numbers
strong
continued its steady march toward 30k in
mid-february
amidst the profound economic
uncertainties of a global pandemic
and the widespread shutdowns in march
the dao
like all major world indices witnessed a
historic sell-off
but then from early april onward
investors found hope
in multi-trillion dollar federal relief
packages
the federal reserve's aggressive
stimulus programs and growing optimism
that a vaccine is on the way
in addition to apple shares of microsoft
amazon
google parent alphabet and facebook have
soared as the pandemic and trends like
remote working
and learning bolster consumers reliance
on new technology
for the s p 500 and the tech laden
nasdaq
these companies have more than
compensated for the declines in
economically sensitive sectors like
energy
while many analysts are wary of a
reversal following such a strong rally
investors say the fundamental drivers of
the run are still intact
particularly for tech companies whose
growth is even more appealing in a world
with
ultra low interest rates who knows where
stocks will go from here the coronavirus
has
really introduced a whole new level of
uncertainty in both directions
investors have really been staggered by
how quickly stocks fell
earlier in the year and how quickly they
since recovered and how fast the dow is
now at 30k
so who knows each 10 000 points gets
easier so
40k might not be out of the question